[Music]
hey everyone my name is arjun and today
i'm going to be showing everyone 12 of
paul murphy's greatest games
for those of you who don't know paul
morphy lived in the 1800s he's
considered by many to be one of the
first unofficial world champions and he
was regularly beating some of the best
players of his time such as lewis
paulson uh adolf anderson and many
others so without further ado let's
begin
the first game i'm going to show today
was played between james mcconnell who
had white and morphy who was playing
with black
so
mcconnell began e4 e5 f4
and here morphe played what's considered
by many to be the most testing line
against the king's gambit
e takes f4 knight f3 and now g5
so g5
is one of the most popular moves it's
also considered to be one of the best
a few other common moves include moves
like d6
as well as d5 which is a move i
personally like
anyway morphe played g5
and now white played bishop to c4 one of
the most popular moves again
another option here is to play h4
immediately trying to undermine the pawn
structure
after bishop to c4 black played bishop
g7 just developing and now white played
d3 which is probably not such a good
move
in this position another a good move
here is to play d4 simply taking the
whole center and when you can play d4
there's really no reason to play the
move d3
after d3 black played h6 and now we're
in a place where there are no other
games that have reaches position among
masters
morphe is already somewhat better
because he has an extra pawn and a lot
of king side space here even though it
may look like his pawns are weak they're
more solid than they may seem
white chose to castle here
knight f6 and now white played c3
another inaccuracy
and i personally don't really like this
move because it doesn't exactly support
g4 because the e4 pawn would hang
also it doesn't block this bishop's
range in a significant way which would
be a normal reason to play this move
now black played a very interesting move
here
he played the move b5 which is a move
only morphe would play
the idea behind b5 is that after bishop
takes b5 as was played in the game black
can play c6 and now the idea is that
soon he can play d5 and open up his
queen side pieces like this
so after c6 white brought the bishop
back to c4 and now black immediately
played d5 so takes takes and now white
played queenie two once again another
slight inaccuracy and the reason i don't
really like this move is because the
queen doesn't have such a great purpose
on e2 because after bishop e6 as was
played in the game the queen isn't
really doing much on the e-file anymore
instead a better move in in this
position would have been to go bishop b5
saving the bishop with tempo
anyway after queen e2 bishop e6 white
played bishop b3 which is once again
another inaccuracy
and a better move here would have been
to go bishop to b5
with check and now white and now black
can't castle for an extra move and white
has chances to continue the game
after bishop to b3 black has a nearly
winning advantage as a matter of fact
black castled uh d4
and then knight e4 and you can see that
f5 and g4 are potential moves for black
in the future gaining more space in
preparing a kingside attack
black white played bishop c2 a good move
so black responded with f5 naturally
knight d2
and now black played knight to c6 which
in itself is not a bad move however in
my opinion knight d7 is slightly
stronger because the idea of knight to
d7 is to eventually play knight f6 and
get your knight to the king side which
is where most of the action is currently
happening
from c6 the knight can't really get over
to the king side so easily sure it could
go like this but it doesn't really have
much of a future from g6 in my view
anyway this isn't a bad move morphe is
still doing very well here
now white played c4 and i'm not exactly
sure why he played this move because it
simply gives away a pawn on d4
however
white was already doing pretty badly so
you can understand his attempt to
complicate the position
after c4 morphe simply played normal
moves bishop takes knight takes and now
knight takes d4 and you can see how
strong morphy's two knights are in the
center of the board
this is something that happens in a lot
of morphe games his pieces get are
really good sometimes even at the cost
of material while his opponent's pieces
don't seem to be doing very much in
comparison
i played queen d3 saving his bishop now
queen b6 so there's a lot of discover
check possibilities now
king h1 is essentially forced otherwise
the discovered checks would deliver mate
soon
knight c2 queen c2 and now knight f2 and
after king g1 there's a common
checkmating motif here that morphe
played
you can take a minute pause the video
and see if you want to find it otherwise
i'll show the answer now it's knight h3
check
king h1 and now queen g1 forcing the
rook to trap the king in the corner and
now checkmate and this is seen in a lot
of puzzles but not so frequently in
games so i think that this is a nice way
to finish this first game
game number two morphe had black once
again
and
this time he was playing against john
william chilton
the game started off in a similar way e4
e5 f4 but this time instead of taking
the pawn black played d5
and now this is called the fock beer
counter gambit and after he takes d5
black played e4 which is not the best
but certainly playable and also a very
aggressive line
after this y played knight to c3 knight
f6
g3 bishop b4
getting this bishop out and now bishop
d2 and so far we're still looking at one
of the main lines of the [ __ ] beer
counter gambit nothing
this game this position has been seen
many times in master level games
black plays e3 here sacrificing his
extra pawn but this is still a popular
move the idea is after bishop takes e3
castles
white should go bishop back to d2
uh stopping this pin again and now black
has a lot of extra development but he is
down two pawns and those two factors
kind of counterbalance each other out
more if he played the move bishop takes
c3 here which is not such a common move
but his idea was probably after bishop
takes c3 when he takes on d5 with this
knight he doesn't want to have to force
a trade because if you saw this position
he would have to trade if he took on d5
after bishop c3
white took with the pawn the best move
and now rook t h rookie 8 track was
played bishop b2
and a bishop g4 so white still has a
slight advantage about half a pawn
similar to his advantage of having the
first move but he is behind in
development and this is a position that
morpheus was often comfortable playing
where he's down where he's ahead a lot
in development or even if he's down a
few pawns in material
here white makes his first inaccuracy of
the game and that was that he played c4
in itself this isn't such a bad move
but his ideas behind this move aren't
correct
white wants to save this g5 pawn but
this isn't the right idea for him he
needs to first save his king and not
worry about material yet
instead a better move here would have
been to go king f2 getting out of this
pin or not that pin that pin still
exists getting out of this pin on his
king
and after something like bishop b2
knight e2 queen d5 and white has a
slight advantage
anyway after c4
morphy played c6
trying to
trying to elicit this trade after which
knight c6 and knight d4 are a
possibility
uh white took the pawn understandably
but this move is actually a losing
blunder in fact white is already down
nearly a rook according to the engine
after knight takes c6 here uh you can
see that white's not black's knight is
going to get to d4 his queen can come
out to b6 and really all of whites all
of black's pieces have sensible squares
to go on
he is down two pawns here but that's not
so important anymore
now white played the move he could have
played last move king f1
and he gets out of this one pin here
however black has two good moves in this
position but one of them virtually wins
the game on the spot so i challenge you
to try to find it
if you'd like
take a minute pause the video see if you
can find it otherwise i'll be showing
the answer right now
the correct move is to play rook takes
e2 double x clam and the idea is after
knight takes knight d4 taking advantage
of this pin on the queen
after queen w1 as was played in the game
bishop e2 was played and now white has a
few legal moves he played king f2 and
this actually allows a check made in
eight moves which is a bit more
challenging than the previous one
however once once again i challenge you
try to find it
if you're stuck i'll show the answer
right now
the checkmate begins with knight to g4
and now there are three legal moves for
white
king g3 loses quite quickly to knight f5
here and on knight f2 a nice checkmate
with two knights
if not king g3
then king e1 loses to queen h4 check g3
and now queen e7 and these discovered
checks are all impossible to stop and
may will actually be forced in less than
two moves
the best move as was played in the game
is king g1
and now a nice sacrifice for morphe
knight to f3 chat
takes is forced and after queen to d4
king g2 queen f2
king h3 queen f3 king h4 note how the
white king is just being drawn out of
its position it's already on the fourth
rank now
there are several moves that went here
morphy played a nice quiet move
he played the move knight to h6
preparing potential knight f5 and also
threatening this checkmate
white played queen g1 and after knight
f5 king g5 queen h5 that's checkmate and
that ended this game
in game number three morphy had white
against a player named a.d ayers
so the game started off with e4 e5
knight f3 no kings gambit this time
knight c6 bishop c4 bishop c5 and now b4
the evans gambit
bishop takes was played main move c3 now
there are two options here for black
bishops a5 and bishop c5 and bishop a5
is more common and that's what's played
here
now white goes d4
trying to break open the center and this
is kind of the main point of the evans
gambit if you're down upon you have to
get quick development otherwise you're
just going to lose eventually
black plays d6 a good move and now queen
b3 so double attacking this f7 pawn and
also taking a lead in development this
is kind of similar to the last game
black plays queen to e7
protecting the pawn now d5 was played
and now knight d4 from black note that
the knight cannot actually be captured
because of this pin on the pawn
now black white plays bishop to b5 and
this is his uh this is morphe's first
inaccuracy of the game because it
doesn't really do anything useful after
the move c6 white simply loses time
so a better move would have been to play
castles because it's it gets the king
out of the center oh wait no sorry that
is not a good move in this position
a better move would have been to play
knight takes d4
and after e takes d4
now
castles is a good move and it gets the
king out of the middle and slight
advantage for white
anyway after knight d4 bishop to b5
uh white play black plays c6 and now
knight takes d4 is forced because you
can't save the queen and bishop at the
same time
now he takes takes
and now detects c6
so uh black plays queen takes e4 and now
we get to a really interesting position
actually i challenge you to try to
evaluate this position what what move
would you play here and who do you think
is better
in reality this position is actually
just equal because both kings are in
about an equal amount of danger
there are two reasonable king moves here
king g2 doesn't seem like such a good
move because it simply brings the king
closer to the center of the board so
either king d1 or king f1 must be played
king d1 was played by morphe but this is
actually the worst of the two options
after king f1 black would play king f8
getting out of this discovery and now
though both kings are pretty unsafe the
position is actually equal
the problem with king d1 is of course
there's the threat of rookie one pinning
the queen
but the problem is after a move like
king f8 white's king is stuck in the
center of the board while black's king
has at least some shelter and black is
somewhat better in this position
instead black plays a blunder bishop g4
and the problem with this is after f3
uh takes takes takes black's idea was he
hopes to win this rook
uh king c2
and now the problem with playing queen
h1 in this position of course is that c
picks b7
discovered attack and threatening this
rook is is good for white
so here black played queen e4 shack
and now morphy actually made another
inaccuracy here that actually makes the
position completely equal once again
the best move in this position would
have been to play bishop to d3
and now after a queen takes h1
uh white plays c takes b7
and after rook b8 queen at queen a4
white wins this bishop
and uh we can see that
uh white is actually about equal in
material he has two bishops for a rook
and two pawns but in general the two
bishops are better than a rook and two
pawns and also black's king is just so
unsafe while meanwhile white's king can
be protected by all of his pieces over
here so white would actually be winning
if he had played this continuation
instead from this position white played
king to b2
and the problem with this
is uh the problem with this move
is that after
after b takes c6
black is doing all right
and the idea is if i play something like
rook to e1 here
and tries to take this pawn
we can do a quick material count we'll
see white has a bishop for three pawns
but black's king isn't in so much danger
anymore and black has a slight advantage
in this position
instead from here black played another
inaccuracy and after this morphe did not
relinquish his advantage
black played bishop takes c3 and the
problem with this is that after knight
takes c3 d-take c3 queen takes c3
there's too many threats on black
there's this threat here
still this discovered attack looms plus
uh c takes b7 and c7 are both
possibilities
black tries to play queenside castles
but now after a simple rookie one queen
g5 c takes king takes black's king is
just so exposed now
morphy played rook to b1
the idea being that of course if queen
takes king a1 and the queen is pinned
uh black played knight f6
and now morphy finished off the game
pretty quickly bishop c6 a nice tactic
queen takes king a1 queen c7 or sorry
king c7
and now he played queen i5
king c8 queen a7 so of course there's
the mate threat here
black has to stop that threat and now
bishop d2
and the computer actually claims a mate
in nine moves but there are several ways
to win this game pinning the queen
mating with these other arrows so black
accordingly resigned
game four was played between morphy and
adolf anderson who's considered to be
one of the greatest players of that
chant of that time besides morphe
it started off with e4 c5 knight f3
uh knight c6 d4 takes takes e6
knight to b5 d6 bishop f4 and this is
the sicilian defense taimana variation
and it's still popular these days at the
top level
here black plays e5
a popular move
bishop e3 and now black played his first
inaccuracy he played f5 here which is an
interesting choice
the most common move here is to play
knight f6 continuing development
normally
after f5 there's actually only one way
to maintain a decent advantage
and i challenge you to try to find the
move
the move is knight 1 to c3
morphy doesn't have to worry about the
f5 pawn he just needs to continue the
development
now black plays f4 presumably the point
of his previous move and once again
white only has one move one way to
continue his advantage and that is to
play the move knight to d5
taking advantage of this weak c7 square
and the fact that black hasn't been
developing his pieces
uh black white play sorry black plays f
takes e3 the only logical continuation
knight takes
and now king f7
now queen f3 and this actually brings
the position back to equal it's morphe's
first inaccuracy this game
the best way to continue was actually to
play knight takes a8
and soon enough the light is going to
get back to c7 and escape after which
white will just be up in exchange
from here after queen f3 the problem is
knight d4 is always looming in some
positions and that and that knight move
with tempo is a problem
after knight to f6
white plays bishop c4 and then knight d4
x-clam the position remains equal
white plays knight takes f6 taking
advantage of this bishop positioning
however after the move d5
bishop takes d5 this chaotic position
actually remains completely equal
after the move king e7
uh if white tries queen to h5
then black can play g takes f6 and we do
a material count black is up a bishop
for a pawn but he's not going to be
mated and if we look at the sample
continuation queen f7 king g6 knight a8
knight takes c2
king e2
and now something like knight back to d4
this chaotic position actually is equal
that all the imbalances can't uh cancel
one another out
however going back to move 14
that's not what anderson played
instead he played the move king to g6
which loses the game now
white actually forced resignation in
only three moves so i challenge you can
you find what moves morphy played from
here
take a minute and pause the video if
you'd like
morphe played queen to h5 check
and after king takes f6
he played the nice move f takes e3
note that castles or just the simple
rook f1
adds another attacker into the game and
black's king is just running around with
nowhere to go
after knight takes c2 played in the game
white played king e2 and now black
resigned if we look at a sample
continuation for example if queen takes
c7
note that this would win the queen
instead if black tries to take this
there's actually a quick forced mate
here like this
pushing the king all the way to the
other side of the board
but of course seeing all these possible
continuations black resigned
after king to e2 on move 17.
the next game was played between the
same two players morphy and anderson and
where she once again had white
this time they entered a king's gambit
and anderson played the same variation
as was seen in the first game between
morphy and mcconnell
g5
morphe played h4 another common move
now g4 knight d5 and black played a
slightly rarer move
he played knight to f6
now knight takes g4 was played by morphy
the most common move here is to play
bishop to c4 and after d5 blocking these
threats on f7
he takes d5
this is the main line with a slight
advantage for black
after knight takes g4
black played knight takes e4 d3 and now
knight g3 and once again we get to an
interesting position
black has this really strong knight on
g3 but he also has a few weak pawns and
his king is definitely a bit exposed so
this position is also about equal
white plays bishop takes f4 not caring
about this rook
and now after knight takes h1
the position actually remains equal
white has a lot of development and a lot
of play against the black king
and black's knight is also trapped but
for the moment black does happen to be
up a full rook
white plays queen e2
uh after bishop e7 there's a mate and
two potential for white this was not
played by anderson uh take a moment see
if you can find it
uh the answer is to play knight f6
taking advantage of this pin
and after king here bishop h6 mate
of course anderson did not fall into
that trap he played queen to e7 instead
now knight f6 was played
and king d8 and now white has another
tactic in this position but it actually
does not win the game however it's the
only move to maintain equality so take a
minute see if you can find it
the move here is to play bishop take c7
and after king takes c7 knight d5
this is a fork on the king and queen
however this was how the game continued
and after king g8 knight takes bishop
takes
we can do a material count and we see
white has a queen and a pawn for a rook
bishop and knight
and this material imbalance actually
favors black slightly
however given that this knight is kind
of trapped on h1 the position remains
about equal white played queen to g4
d6 was played
queen f4 threatening this pawn
rook g8 and now morphy played queen
takes f7
a slight inaccuracy a better move here
is to play bishop to e2
uh just developing his pieces
after queen f7 bishop h4 and this is the
first new position of the game the first
position that has not yet been seen
among master level games
after bishop 84 black white played king
to d2
and rookie 8 potentially bishop e1 is a
threat
knight a3
knight a6 and now this is an era from
anderson that gives morphe the upper
hand
there are several moves that are good
here for white
uh the the best one here is to play
queen f4 and after bishop e7
rookie one
you can see that white's pieces are all
doing pretty well black's knight isn't
too relevant on a6 while this knight can
go to b5 or c4
and black has not yet developed his
queen side
morphy did not choose this instead he
played queen to h5 which is
not quite as good as the other move
after bishop f6 which was played
white played queen takes h1
and now
black played bishop takes b2 a seemingly
natural move but this actually loses on
the spot and this was the losing mistake
instead black couldn't have tried bishop
to g5 after king c3 bishop to d7 but
black white still has a decent advantage
because of his extra material
white's king is definitely weaker than
blacks but since white has extra
material he's still doing well
instead bishop b2 loses
the problem with bishop b2 is white
white played bishop sorry queen to h4
and now after king d7 rook b1 bishop a3
white has this nice tactic queen to a4
winning back the winning back the piece
and that was the original problem with
playing bishop takes b2
after queen to h4
the bishop will not be able to take the
knight because of this tactic
so
after queen a4 black resigned because
after king d8
queen takes a3 we do a material count
white is up a queen for a rook and
knight which might not seem like such a
huge material advantage however in a
position like this where the black king
is exposed and also he hasn't developed
many of his pieces this will prove
decisive ultimately between two good
players
so black resigned
the sixth game was played between lewis
paulson another great player from the
time and paul morphy and morphy had
black
e4 e5
so this is the four knights
and now black played bishop c5 which is
not the most common move but certainly
not a bad move
castles castles and now i played knight
takes e5 the most popular move
and this does not immediately give away
a knight because after knight takes d4
white is forking these two pieces
after bishop d6 takes takes the position
remains about equal
after knight takes e5 as was played in
the game morphy played an interesting
alternative he played rook to e8
sacrificing the pawn for some extra
development
so
paulson played the natural knight takes
c6 but this actually gives morphy a
slight advantage
a better move would have been to play
knight to f3 simply retreating the
knight
and if morphe tries to take back this
knight and take back this pawn
then
morphy's rook isn't doing too great on
e4 and also white will have some tempo
to get his pieces out and white is a
little bit better here
the problem with knight takes c6 is
after g takes c6 morphe is going to get
this bishop out really quickly and this
outweighs the cost of a pawn
bishop c4 is slightly inaccurate
a better place to put the bishop would
have been on e2
where
this bishop g4 and knight to g4 threats
are stopped
however morphy returns the favor on his
next move he plays the move b5 which
attempts to gain queen side space
but it just forces the bishop back to e2
which was already a better square for it
instead
morphy should have played knight to g4
preparing threats on h2 and f2 and he's
doing pretty well in this position
after b5 bishop e2
morphy took back his pawn
now material is equal
white plays bishop f3 rook e6 c3 so both
sides are playing pretty well now
white of course wants to go d4 next move
so morphe plays queen to d3 which is a
nice idea it stops this pawn from
advancing and also makes it hard to
develop the queen side
here white begins to go astray he plays
b4 and the problem with b4 is that it
pushes the bishop back to what could be
a better square
and it also tries to gain space on the
queen side but is really just creating
weaknesses
morphe played bishop to b6 a slightly
better move would have been to play
bishop d6 aiming towards the king's side
after bishop b6 a4 was played and white
continues to play on the queen side but
this isn't the right idea
after takes takes white played black
played one more inaccuracy his last one
of the game bishop to d7 and the problem
with this is that it allows queen a6
for uh threatening this queen
and if the queen tries to retreat
then white can go d4 and he's doing fine
here
thus a better move would have been to go
bishop to b7 stopping that
after bishop d7
white played his final mistake rook to
a2 and now morphy kept the advantage
what black played rookie eight
putting his rook into into
uh the battle and now
uh morphy has a big threat in this
position so i challenge you can you find
his threat
the winning move if it were morphe's
turn would have been to play queen takes
f1
followed by
rook to e1 checkmate so white stopped
that but now it allows an incredible
move from morphe so i challenge you can
you find it
take a minute and pause the video if
you'd like i'm now going to reveal the
answer
the winning move is queen takes f3
and after g takes f3 rook g6 king h1
white goes oh sorry black goes bishop h3
now after bishop g2 king g1 there's
going to be a type of windmill tactic
after rook d1
black played bishop g2 king g1
and now if you imagine that white
cooperated for a second black could
simply check like this
and take all of white's pieces like this
however this wasn't exactly what
happened in the game after rook d1
bishop g2 king g1 bishop f3 king f1
and now black has a forced checkmate in
four moves here so i challenge you to
try to find it
the winning move here is to play rook to
g2
and
now white actually has no good options
here if you play something like queen a4
simply
rook takes f2 king g1 rook g2
and now something like this
morphe did not play that move but he
played a different winning move he
played bishop to g2 repeating ruth once
king to g1 bishop h3
now after king h1 he played bishop takes
f2 threatening this checkmate
this move was forced to stop mate
so takes takes
and now rookie two so black's rooks are
either going to give checkmate or
they're going to win a lot of material
well i tried rook a1
but after rook h6 d4 bishop e3
this mate is coming
and
the only way to stop it is to play rook
f2
accordingly white resigned
the next game was played between paul
morphy with white and thomas herbert
warl with black and as you can see white
actually gave him knight odds in this
game
we started off with another king's
gambit
and black plays what would be a main
line if morphe did have his queenside
knight but maybe it's not the best
choice in an odds game because in an
odds game it's up to the person giving
the odds to win the game
black doesn't need to make the position
tactical if he just maintains his
advantage he'll end up winning
either way
white plays bishop c4 now g4
and now white sacrifice is a knight
after g takes f3
um castles black plays a slight a slight
inaccuracy
bishop of h6
and the problem with this is that he's
trying to hold on to his f4 pawn which
isn't the right way to play
it would have been better to play move
like bishop g7
now queen takes f3 was played
and now black plays a move that actually
throws away his whole opening advantage
knight c6 and the position is actually
almost equal now
morphy plays a nice sacrifice here you
can take a moment try to find it if
you'd like
the move was bishop takes f7 opening up
the king even further
now the best way to refute any sacrifice
is to try to accept it like like black
did with king takes f7
now queen h5 was played king g7 and
bishop takes f4
so and once uh black once morphe brings
all of his pieces out and black won't
have any more advantage because his king
is just so unsafe
black took back on f4 rook takes f4
knight h6 stopping these threats on f7
and now rook adaf1 so this move is
completely fine the the position is
still about equal
where if he could have forced a draw
here if he would have wanted would rook
to g4
and after this
there's simply no way for black to
escape all the tracks
so this would have been a draw had
morphe wanted it however he was most
likely trying to win this game
so he played rook a to f1
and now queen eight stopping any more
potential threats on f7
uh queen h4
and now d6
and this is a slight mistake again it
gives white the advantage
the best move would have been to play
something like queen g6 stopping a queen
f6 idea
d6 was played and now after queen f6
king g8 queen h6 morphe has one of his
pieces back
black plays the move bishop d7 here
which allows the check made in five
moves from white
uh the better move would have been to
play something like bishop e6
and now after d5 white is going to win
another piece back and this position is
really good for white because he has so
much peace activity he's only going to
be down one piece at the end of this
exchange
i challenge you can you find the mitten
5 here
you can take a minute pause if you'd
like
i'll reveal the answer now
the correct move would have been to play
rook f8 check and after queen takes
queen g5
queen g7 is forced
now here black interposes with all of
his pieces but ultimately falls prey to
mate
in the game however morphe missed this
move he played rook 4 to f3 he still has
an advantage but it's not it's not
completely winning yet
black brought his
knight back to e7
and now h4 so he wants to bring this
pawn to h5 and attack this knight when
it comes to g6 like this
black played bishop g4
takes here
and now takes on on g6 but this allows a
check made in three moves so
if you'd like you can try to find it
the move was rook to f8 and after taking
these white has a nice checkmate like
this
black's rooks are actually what's
stopping his king from getting out of
the mate
the next game morphy had black and he
was playing against napoleon marache
so white started with e4 e5 knight f3
knight c6
and b4 so another evans gambit
takes on b4 c3 bishop a5 the main line
once again
d4 takes
and now white plays e5 deviating from
theory
and this isn't the right time to try to
gain space in the center because white
needs to somehow find compensation for
being down a pawn
after e5
black played d5 the best move
countering in the center
takes on d6 takes
castles in 97 stopping any pot stopping
any potential threats on the e-file
knight g5 was played and after castles
note that there aren't really any big
threats on f7 and uh morphy's leading
development is crushing
note that in this exact position he's
actually up two pawns plus development
and his pieces are actually doing better
so he really has all the possible
advantages in this position
white played bishop d3 morphy stop the
threat with bishop f5
takes takes and now note that white only
has one piece that's been developed and
even that might become a target soon
bishop a3 was played
trying to win this rook
after queen g6
black took white took the rook
but now note that he has once again only
one developed piece and that piece is
doing something on f8 i don't really
know what
white tried to save his piece
but now
black gets his third pawn and now he has
a knight in three pawns for a rook which
is an overwhelming material advantage
white tried bishop c1 hoping to reroute
the bishop but now you notice actually
none of white's pieces have even come
off the back rank and all of his
all of his remaining pawns are on their
original squares
meanwhile morphy only really has one
piece that's not doing well well maybe
two if you include this bishop on a5 and
even those are going to get into the
game soon
white developed with bishop to f4
rick d8 getting his rook into the game
queen c2 and i'm knight c to d4 so this
knight is headed for f3 now where
it cannot be captured
white plays queen to e4 and now there's
a tactic from for morphe here i
challenge you can you find it
uh you can take a second and pause the
video if you'd like
i'm going to show the answer now
the move is knight to g3
and the point is
if something like queen g6 which is the
normal response black has this nice
checkmate an id to e2 and how often does
this happen a checkmate with two nights
this is actually how the game ended
if instead uh white tried to take then
the queen hangs of course
so this move was
won the game and this was how it
finished
this next game was played with morpheus
white against hubert knott who had black
this time morphy gave rook odds
the game started off with another king's
gambit and the same line with g5
morphed valve quickly and quick
development is of the essence when
you're down material so
morphe's intentions are clear he needs
to either give checkmate or he'll lose
quick or he'll lose eventually being
down a rook
g4 is played
and now d4 and really there's two
possible outcomes to this game
either white mates black
with his extra development or black
survives and
eventually wins with his extra material
takes on f3 castle is now d5 and this is
a good move from black one of the best
in the position and instead of trying to
hold on to his material he's focusing on
development after all he is already off
a rook knight in pawn so we can afford
to lose a few pieces
takes on d5
bishop to g4
queen d3 now takes on g2
so now morphy played
rook to f2 and i'm not exactly sure why
he didn't play rook f4 possibly it's
because he didn't really see what to
continue after bishop h5
either way after rook f2
black played c6 and now white sacrificed
yet another piece
so now after king takes
if we do a material count we see black
is up a rook bishop and knight that's 11
points which is a lot
white takes on f4 now there's some
possibilities of discovered checks
but black just plays knight f6 stopping
them and so far black has actually
played really well this game he hasn't
made any serious mistakes and he has a
huge material advantage and his king is
not about to get checkmated and the
evaluation is actually nearly plus 10
for him
e5 was played by white hoping to get the
knight out of the way
black just defends it with his other one
knight c3 is played bishop g7 knight e4
and now black light h6 which gives away
some of his advantage
because nitro g5 isn't such a big threat
in this position
perhaps black calculated this following
line knight e4 bishop g5 knight f2 queen
b3
and now bishop d8
and he saw after rook takes d8
that he is technically down a queen but
you'll notice that black has two rooks
two bishops and two knights for the
queen so this is of course a winning
advantage
regardless black is still uh black still
has a winning advantage after h6 but
it's just not as good as it had been
earlier
white took on f6
knight takes f6
now bishop e5 and morphy's pieces are
suddenly coming to life
this rook
knight and queen are all in the game
black played rook f8 and now the
position is once again close to equal
knight takes f6 bishop f6 and bishop f6
and black is still up a rook but now
there's some more the real possibilities
of discovered checks
a queen to d7 and now white has a tricky
immediate win so i challenge you you can
try to find it morphe did not actually
find it he played the move queen to h7
instead i challenge you can you find
this win
you can take a minute and pause if you'd
like
uh the winning move was d5
now the idea is
if black simply takes back
bishop to c3 and after king eight queen
g6 mate will come soon
instead if black just does nothing say
he plays like a6
queen e4
and black is going to be made in a few
moves
if black tries to run away
then queen g6 rook f7 now bishop g5 and
queen g8 is going to come soon with a
crushing position
so this move would have won instead
uh white black white played queen h7
king e8 followed
queen g6 is played rook f7 and now
bishop g5 and morphe is still using this
pin on the rook
but it's not as strong as it would have
been in the previous line
in this position black panicked he
played the move bishop to f3
which simply gives away a bishop here
and i'm not exactly sure why he would
have played this move
instead white black could have tried to
move like queen to f5 sacrificing his
queen
but white cannot actually deliver
checkmate
if he tries to do this there's no
immediate check made in this position
either way black played bishop f3 and
after brook takes f3 morphe did not
throw away his advantage
he played rookie 3 check
bishop h6 or d7 and maid is coming soon
bishop takes
queen takes
and now murphy decided to win the queen
so black resigned here
game number 10 was played between morphy
and his dad alonzo morphy and paul had
white in this position
giving his father rook odds
start off with e4 e5
the two knights defense
and in this position when y does have a
rook the main moves to go knight a5
and there are a lot of interesting
possibilities after this position
however in this
black plane knight takes d5
and normally this is a bad position
because white has this interesting
sacrifice the knight takes f7
however given that
white is missing his rook on a1 this is
still a winning position for black
this was what happened in the game
and after knight to c3 black decided to
give away his knight
um after
bishop takes d5 king d6 the knight could
potentially retreat to e6 protecting the
king somewhere and black still has a
good position given that he won bl
white's knight on f7 earlier
however it would have been better to
instead not give away the knight and
play move like knight to e7
after knight to d4 white played bishop
takes d5 king d6 queen f7
and now black played the move bishop e6
which may seem like it's a fine move but
white has actually attained equality now
so a better way to play would have been
queen e7 hoping for a queen trade of
course any queen trade in this position
would give a winning advantage to black
and if white tries knight e4 simply king
d7
and black's king is somewhat safe now
bishop e6 and now after takes takes
knight e4
uh black's king is forced to run to the
center of the board
a better move would have been king c6
here after queen takes bishop to d6
and this does give away the knight but
if we do a material count
a white has a knight and a pawn
for one of black's rooks and this
advantage normally gives a slight
advantage to black however given that
black's king is so unsafe the position
is slightly better for white
um alonzo morphe on the other hand
wanted to maintain his extra knight but
now after c4 king e4 queen e6 black's
king is even closer to white's territory
than to his own
queen d4 hoping to protect the knight
or hoping to protect the king
a white played queen g4 king d3 queen e2
king c2
and now d3 king takes c1
and this allows a checkmate in one move
which looks pretty nice castles
uh instead black could have played king
to b1 which would have survived a little
bit longer
but after king after castles these
discovered checks will end the game soon
and there and the computer declares a
mate in eight moves
this was the real end to the game
and this is checkmate
uh this next game was played between
morphy with white and george salmon with
black and this was actually a
blindfolded game from morphe
uh the game started off with another
evans gambit
and this time black did not accept the
gambit but he played d5 which is unusual
but definitely not a bad move and it's
certainly playable
e takes d5 is played and now knight b4
and the idea is that black wants to take
this pawn eventually
castles and now white played knight
blacklight knight to e7
um another possibility wouldn't play
knight f6 instead with basically the
same intentions
97
knight takes e5 and out castles
a better move here is to just take back
the pawn if we do material count
material is equal
but since black's knights are a bit tied
up here white is a little bit better
castles d4 bishop d6
and now knight c3
and morphe has a slighted a slight
advantage because he is up one pawn and
his pieces are a little bit more
actively placed
black played bishop to f5 which is not
the best and a better move would have
been to play c6 trying to break down
white's center
after d takes c6
um
bishop takes e5 and now knight takes c6
sure black is down a pawn but white has
this loose pawn on e5 an isolated pawn
on c2 and a2
uh and he is a little bit worse but not
doing too badly
bishop f5 was played in the game though
black played white played bishop to b3
protecting c2
and now a5
once again in this position c6 would
have been a better move trying to break
down the center
a5
now a3
a4
so white took on a4 and black took on g5
so once again if we do a material count
we'll see white is up a pawn but his
knight isn't so great on a4
white is still better though because he
has this nice knight on e5 as well as
the pawn advantage
white played c4 and now black played a
nice move here
he played rook takes a4
and
if white had played bishop takes a4
black goes knight to c3
after queen b3
white black brings his knight to e2 and
gets it to d4 where he's in the center
of the board and though uh white black
is down in exchange or work for a knight
since his knight is good and this knight
is a bit loose white's advantage is not
nearly the full exchange however white
is still better
morphe did not allow that though he
played c takes d5 which is the best move
and after rook a5 queen f3 getting the
queen out
bishop g6 was chosen by black
now rookie one just getting the rook out
and now bishop b4
here white has one move that
virtually ends the game immediately i
challenge you can you find it morphe
played the simple rookie two however
this was not best
take a minute pause the video see if you
can find the winning move here
the winning move in this position was
bishop to g5 which is crushing
after bishop takes e1 rook takes e1
when black tries to just take this
this will win the night and it's
surprisingly hard to stop this sequence
of moves from occurring
rookie 2 certainly keeps some advantage
though
now black played knight f5
bishop b2 protecting g4
queen
a8 uh targeting this line and also this
pawn
and now g3
queen a7
and now morphy had one more strong move
in this position
which would have been to play
h4
and the idea is after uh bishop takes a3
white goes knight to c4
uh and
instead of bishop takes a3 if something
like knight to d6 had been played
then h5 bishop f5
and g4 and these pawns are going to come
down the board
but after g3 queen i7
white just played knight takes g6
and after h takes g6 morphy made one
more inaccuracy he played rook to e5 and
now the position is actually roughly
equal
the problem with this move
is
uh black can play something like knight
takes d4 which would have been the best
move and after queen to d1
he gets this bishop as well
and a material account shows that
material is equal and white doesn't
really have any more favorable
imbalances so the position is basically
equal
a black played bishop to a3 though and
now this gives back the advantage
d6 was played by white
note that the idea is to remove a
defender of the of the a3 bishop
bishop b4
takes on a5 queen d5
this pawn can push down the board and
this bishop is also double attacked
b6 was played
now d7 queen a8
rook c1
uh just targeting this c7 pawn
takes on d5 bishop takes b5
now bishop c6 knight d6 and d5 were
played and we get into an end game
however this is an end game that's
definitely winning for white because
this pod is so strong and black's rook
can never really really leave the back
rank because otherwise the pawn will
promote
bishop d2 was played rick d1 bishop g5
f4
now bishop d8
oh white played bishop to a3
f5 and now rookie 1 potentially rookie 8
isn't a rook e8 is an idea
king f7
uh white took this pawn
i note that this would lose immediately
due to this
oh black played rook h8 i'll just go
through the next few moves a bit quickly
and now morphe's plan is pretty simple
all he has to do is really get this king
to c8 somehow
and then he'll win this bishop and
there's surprisingly little that black
can do about this
black tried this
but now he was simply forced to move his
rook back and forth because if you think
about there's not really any more
logical continuations for black as he
can never take this rook due to white
promoting
so eventually we got here
black is forced to get his bishop out of
the way but then white promotes now
white's just going to take this pawn
followed by the other pawns and so of
course black resigned
the 12th and final game i have for today
is between paul morphy and an unnamed
opponent who had black
it began e4 e5
and f4 another king's gambit and this
game was happened to be played in a
blindfold simul so morpheus playing
several opponents all while blindfolded
he takes f4 knight f3 and on black
played c6 so presumably he wants to go
d5
knight to c3 black played bishop to b4
which kind of goes against the whole
point of black's previous move
if he'd wanted to attend d5 then why not
play d5 in this exact position
after this but white played bishop c4
and now bishop takes c3 and this gives
morphe the opportunity to just develop
his bishop in queen after d takes c3 and
white's already actually much better in
this position
black played knight to e7
and now morphy played a nice move queen
to d6 which is an excellent outpost for
the queen it blocks the advantage of
this d-pawn
in general if you can block the advance
of the d-pawn in a structure like this
it makes it really hard to develop the
queen side because then it's because
then it's hard to make a an open line
for the bishop like that
black castle bishop f4
uh knight to g6 bishop g5 queenie eight
and now castles
so uh you can see uh all of white's
pieces except this rook on a1 are in the
game and being useful meanwhile black
only has one piece that is useful and
that's his knight on g6 and i don't see
how these three pieces are ever gonna
get into the game
kha was played
rookie one getting his final piece into
the game
f6 and now morphy played a nice
sacrifice by no means was this the only
move but i challenge you can you find it
uh the winning move or one of the
winning moves was to play e5
and after f5 sorry after f takes g5
the problem is white can go knight takes
g5 and now this knight f7 threat is
going to come soon
flat tries to stop it like this
white can simply go like this and now
he's double attacking this knight and
will win the game
so black played f5 which is a good try
knight d4 f4 and now e6 and this opens
up even more lines this is a common
theme throughout all of morphe's games
if you can open up lines in your head in
development that oftentimes gives way to
a winning attack
d takes c6 knight takes c6 bishop takes
and now rook takes e6
queen c8 and now a white sacrifice is
another piece rook takes g6 and black
has absolutely no defenders anymore even
this rook on f8 isn't really doing much
to defend the king well white has at
least three attackers and this rook can
easily come into the game as well
each takes queen takes queen f5
now white played a nice queen sacrifice
here brook takes f4
although saddle moves when such as queen
h5 as well
rook takes
a queen takes g6 virtually forced rook
takes king h7
now morphy did a quick windmill
to win this queen
after king takes g6 he played bishop f4
this knight is double attacked and
there's no way to protect it so black
resigned because the ensuing enyam would
be easily winning
so that concludes the 12 games i have to
show today
i hope you enjoyed i hope you learned
something and i'll see you next time
thanks
you